what are the chances that he can get
book smart too well i wouldn't say no to
that obviously that's really cool that
me too
i mean you really gonna tell these
people that the only thing they have
left of their son was a letter that you
wrote to yourself so you and connor tell
us something please right um i love how
excited everyone is for this movie to
come out obviously it was a huge hit on
broadway ben played the role for so long
but you're just 24 years old ben is only
three years older than you at 27 but
there has been such an intense reaction
to him playing this teen role what is
your reaction to that and and what do
you have to say to those fans it doesn't
feel like a big deal to me
for a long time we've been sort of
tapping into our high school selves late
into our 20s and that's what we are
actors for i think that evan hansen is
best performed by ben platt as well and
ben does such an amazing and beautiful
job at playing him and i think that he
does it so well and i and i think
he's such an icon and um i'm really
happy that he is um playing evan in the
in the film version as well as on
broadway i never meant to make it such a
mess have you given beanie any sneak
peeks to your role in dear evan hansen
because obviously she's going on to do
her own broadway gorgeousness with funny
girl but do you guys give each other
little sneak peeks we have
um some very secretive messages being
sent to each other constantly really
i've seen oh my god also she's my best
bud she is my everything that w magazine
cover that just recently came out hello
she is a queen yes no we had an evan
hansen um group chat going between me
ben and beanie and we were sharing
photos all the time and i'm just so
proud of her and everything she's doing
and i know that i i'm just so glad that
i've met her and booksmart brought us
together because we're gonna be best
friends for life she's just really the
most special person ever
nobody knows that we are fun we know
they need to know who is they what are
the chances that we can get book smart
too and then also get ben involved as
well well i wouldn't say no to that
obviously um
it's an immediate yes on my end so i'm
gonna just send it to the movie gods and
hope that something happens the movie
gods olivia wilde whoever's listening
whoever's listening if you're out there
book smarter fast forward out of college
see what that was like for them oh i'm
liking what we're yeah things are never
going to be the same but it was perfect
and i may not have before but i see you
now and you're all
pretty great
don't let college pick it up girl your
career is going at a hundred miles per
hour these days so many fun projects
coming up for you we have rosaline we
have you playing george clooney and
julia robert's daughter are you just
constantly feeling pinch me moments or
does it feel like you know what at the
end of the day this is just my job
no i do not the latter is very crazy to
me that this is just like my job and
this is just i feel so grateful to to be
doing what i'm doing and and to be
enjoying it and to be working and i i
cannot even tell you how lucky i feel
and i really do know how lucky i am i am
so grateful but i literally can't even
comprehend the idea of george clooney
and julia roberts being my parents but
they are going to be my parents soon and
i don't know how i i need to just be
normal i just need to figure out how to
be calm for that introduction um
because they're the two of them like one
of them is is a lot but then two of them
at once it's like
oh
it's just a lot i just really don't know
how to i really feel like super grateful
and i'm so excited i'm gonna go to
australia for the first time in my life
to make that movie and it's going to be
very fun and i'm shooting rosalind um as
we speak so i'm just very excited to be
working and i really do love work and
it's super fulfilling to me and to be
able to explore all different kinds of
characters and to be a part of different
genres is very exciting
you don't know how much you've given my
family and me your mom was played by amy
adams in this movie like so flippin cool
did you get any advice from her and did
you fan girl a little bit the first time
you met her of course how could you not
working with someone like amy adams you
think she has done every movie you've
possibly seen and she is so good in
literally everything she does and she is
the nicest sweetest person i've ever met
she is so kind i really was just in awe
of the way she presented herself on set
i asked her about actually like doing
promotion for for movies and stuff and
how she cuz she's must she's just
constantly working and she's constantly
promoting movies and she was just like
remember to keep the light in constantly
and that was a piece of advice that i
really will take with me forever because
it's true she's just like it you just
have to bring the light with you and i
think that that is how i would describe
amy herself she really is just such a
light um everywhere she goes and i and i
am so
grateful that i got to be able to like
witness that three feet away from her
face and get to connect with her and and
act with her and bring a scene to life
with her it was i i'll never forget it
and um i want to work with her again and
work with her i get it again
[Music]